Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je suis bègue.
Je suis bègue depuis l’âge de sept ans
et même si je ne sais
toujours pas pourquoi,
je peux vous dire que les « que »,
les « pe » et les « te »
étaient mes pires ennemis.
Le plus dur, c'était quand je devais
appeler mes copines au téléphone.
Je me préparais,
je respirais.
(Inspire)
Une grande inspiration.
(Expire)
Une longue expiration.
Je composais le numéro -
(Mime la composition au cadran)
je sais, je ne suis pas si jeune -
(Rires)
j’entendais la sonnerie et dès que ça
décrochait, je disais tout d’une traite :
(Inspire)
« Bonjour, Catherine à l’appareil,
est-ce que je pourrais parler
à Isabelle, s’il vous plaît ? »
Et là, j’entendais : « Oui bien sûr,
qui est à l’appareil ? »
Clic !
Et là, je raccrochais.
Pendant toutes ces années où j’ai usé et
abusé de la patience de mon entourage,
j’ai finalement beaucoup plus appris
à écouter qu’à parler.
Comme mon cerveau n’a plus à réfléchir,
j’ai tout le temps
pour observer les autres,
et c’est mon corps,
c’est tout mon corps, qui écoute.
Je ne le savais pas encore,
mais je commençais à pratiquer
la lecture instantanée du non-verbal.
La vie m’a donné raison
puisque l’on sait aujourd’hui
que les mots ne pèsent que 7 %
dans l’impact d’une communication.
Attention, ça ne veut pas dire que
les mots ne sont pas importants.
Ça veut juste dire que les mots,
s’ils ne sont pas valorisés
avec un ton, une énergie,
s’ils ne sont pas exprimés avec clarté,
on ne les entend pas,
on ne les retient pas.
Ce que nous dit ce schéma,
c’est que finalement, presque tout se joue
sur la voix et le non verbal.
C'est à l'âge de quinze ans, après des
années passées chez les orthophonistes,
que j’ai rencontré la personne
qui allait redonner vie à ma parole.
J’arrive en troisième dans le cours de
français de Monsieur Sylvain Gressot,
qui n’était pas un homme ordinaire.
Le fait est qu’il a été le premier
à prendre en compte le fait que, quand
je récitais par cœur et quand je lisais,
je ne bégayais pas.
Il a appelé mes parents avec mon accord
et il a proposé de me faire travailler
mon expression orale.
Qu’est-ce qui s’est passé ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il a fait exactement ?
Eh bien, il m'a remise en mouvement.
Faire des galipettes, dire des mots
compliqués pour moi tout haut,
courir, lancer une balle,
rester concentrée sur cette balle
qu’il fallait absolument que je rattrape
tout en disant un son difficile.
Tout plein d’exercices où,
dès que je bloquais,
il fallait absolument
que je trouve une solution
pour dire ce que j’avais à dire :
me remettre en mouvement, trouver un mot
alternatif, poser un temps de silence,
tout ça pour surtout
ne pas rester tétanisée.
C’est pour ça que je parle
avec autant de fluidité aujourd’hui,
parce que j’ai mis en place
tout plein de techniques
qui me permettent
de voir arriver l’obstacle,
et hop ! de dégainer ma solution.
Escape !
Ces années passées avec -
Cette année passée avec Sylvain Gressot,
à qui je me permets
de rendre hommage aujourd’hui,
m’a appris que
je sais finalement autant communiquer
sans les mots qu’avec les mots.
J’ai fait de ce handicap une force
parce qu’il m’a fallu
une vraie dizaine d’années,
pour parler comme je parle aujourd’hui,
après cette rencontre.
En fait, après ça, je n’ai jamais lâché.
Je n’ai plus jamais accepté
de me faire bloquer par un mot.
Ce qui est génial, c’est que la vie,
elle m’a donné tellement d’opportunités
pour pratiquer, pour m’entraîner.
La prise de parole est devenue
une véritable alliée pour moi.
Je suis rentrée dans la vie active
pour payer mes cours de théâtre
et finalement c’est l’entreprise
qui m’a permis de me mettre en scène.
Comme par exemple ce jour où
j’ai dû présenter la stratégie
publicitaire européenne de ma société
devant plusieurs centaines
de clients et revendeurs.
Imaginez
la patinoire de Courchevel redécorée
totalement aux couleurs de ma société.
C’était le grand show à l’américaine.
Tout le monde s’exprimait :
le président, le directeur général,
le directeur des ventes,
le directeur marketing,
le directeur de la communication
et finalement la petite dernière,
c’est-à-dire moi.
Inutile de vous dire que
j’ai eu largement le temps
de sentir le trac monter.
En plus, il faisait glacial
dans cette patinoire.
Et me voilà projetée sur scène,
mon discours en mains, celles-ci
ayant décidé de trembler librement.
Et comble du bonheur,
pour être sûr que l’on me voie bien,
mon image était projetée en grand écran.
Donc tout le monde voyait
mes feuilles trembler.
Et là, j’aperçois enfin le pupitre
qui lui était stable.
Merci pupitre.
Il a été l’appui qui m’a permis
de retrouver ma confiance.
Et du coup, j'ai pu embarquer
tout le monde.
Et vous savez quoi ? J’ai été applaudie
comme une star à la fin.
Parce que je me suis rendu compte
que parler devant les autres, finalement,
c’est leur raconter une histoire.
Quand on est convaincu de quelque chose,
quand on le vit pleinement,
quand on l’incarne,
on est tout à fait capable
de réembarquer des équipes,
de relancer des projets.
On n’est pas tous des orateurs-nés,
c’est évident,
on n’est pas tous des Barack Obama
ou des Simone Veil,
mais on est tous capables,
le jour où on en a besoin,
de communiquer,
de faire passer un message.
C'est possible et ça se travaille.
Et c’est ce qui a motivé
ma deuxième vie professionnelle.
Je me suis spécialisée en prise de parole
et efficacité relationnelle.
Parce que l’un ne va pas sans l’autre,
ni l’autre sans l’un.
Une prise de parole réussie,
c’est une prise de parole préparée
avec trois niveaux de préparation.
Il y a le physique,
le technique et le mental.
C’est physiquement que
l’on entre en relation avec autrui.
Ce qui se passe dans la rencontre,
c'est d'abord par le regard.
Vous voyez ce bébé ?
Il ne sait pas encore parler,
et pourtant, il vous dit déjà
bonjour avec les yeux.
C’est le fameux bonjour des yeux.
Je ne sais pas si vous vous en souvenez,
mais en arrivant,
je me suis posée un petit peu,
là, devant vous.
D’abord pour me connecter,
pour vous accueillir,
et pour m’assurer de votre disponibilité.
C’est vrai, à quoi ça sert de commencer
à parler si l’autre ne vous écoute pas ?
Physiquement, il faut aussi prendre
en compte la respiration.
Et puis la mise en énergie.
Parce que pour le jour J,
il faut avoir la pêche.
Il faut ajuster sa voix, chauffer sa voix,
penser à s’entraîner, à bien articuler.
Et ancrer sa posture.
Tous ces éléments physiques
vont faciliter
la communication verbale
et non verbale de notre intervention.
Et il y a la préparation technique.
D’abord, c’est l’introduction
et la conclusion,
qui sont deux moments forcément chargés
d’émotion, à apprendre par cœur.
Et derrière, il y a ce que j’appelle
la mise en scène des mots.
Ça veut dire installer des variations
de rythme pour éviter la monotonie,
et intégrer la ponctuation naturelle
et les silences.
Ah les silences !
Les silences, c'est un temps de pause.
C'est un temps de respiration nécessaire
pour notre public.
Ils ont besoin de digérer
ce que l’on vient de dire.
En même temps, le silence,
c’est aussi un merveilleux outil
de maintien en haleine.
Parce que si je me tais,
vous allez vouloir entendre la suite.
Une présentation sans silence est une
présentation dont on veut se débarrasser.
Le dernier niveau de préparation,
c'est le mental.
Ce qui se passe, c’est que quand
on n’est pas convaincu de quelque chose,
notre corps le dit à notre place.
Notre posture physique va impacter
notre pouvoir de conviction.
Le mental, c’est aussi une histoire
de confiance en soi.
Il n’y a pas photo,
il faut aller travailler
le fait d’accueillir ses émotions
et de faire face à l’imprévu.
Un des outils
les plus utilisés actuellement
pour parler de soi, pour parler
d’un projet, c’est le pitch.
C'est aussi le plus difficile.
Le pitch, c’est l’art de convaincre
en allant à l’essentiel
en moins d’une minute.
Le pitch, c’est la bande-annonce
de votre projet.
Le pitch, c’est le scénario
qui raconte votre histoire.
Un bon pitch, c'est la complétude
du fond et de la forme.
C’est le « quoi dire »
et le « comment le dire ».
Il y a trois grandes étapes dans le pitch.
Un, capter l’intérêt ;
deux, créer le désir ;
et trois, ancrer les bénéfices.
Pour capter l’intérêt, il est très
important de pouvoir communiquer son Why,
le fameux Why de Simon Sinek,
sa raison d’être.
Travailler son why,
c’est identifier sa différence,
c’est marquer sa singularité
avec sa motivation profonde.
Notre why va également impacter
de manière très positive
notre mental et notre confiance en soi.
Créer le désir. (Rit)
Voilà, vous avez vu, j’ai créé le désir.
Créer le désir, c’est ce que j’essaye
de faire en ce moment.
C’est essayer de vous persuader de prendre
au sérieux la préparation de vos pitchs.
Parce qu'un pitch, ça ne s'improvise pas.
D’ailleurs, je ne sais pas si vous savez -
Est-ce que vous saviez que
la prise de parole en public
fait partie des plus grandes peurs
universelles de l’humain ?
Ensuite, il faut incarner son pitch.
Et on va l’incarner d’abord
avec conviction,
avec énergie, avec le sourire.
Et avec authenticité.
Si pas d’authenticité, pas d’émotion.
Si pas d’émotion,
pas d’empreinte chez notre interlocuteur.
On ne va pas laisser cette empreinte.
Parce que la manière
que l’on a de s’exprimer
va impacter la qualité de la relation
que l’on installe.
Et ça, ça passe par la parole libre.
Qu’est-ce qui fait que
j’ai décidé d’intituler ce TEDx
« Du bégaiement à la parole libre » ?
Pourquoi est-ce que
j’ai choisi ces deux mots,
« Parole libre » ?
Vous avez peut-être
une petite idée maintenant.
Le bégaiement, c'est la prison des mots.
C'est cette impossibilité de dire les
choses comme on veut et quand on veut.
Alors saluons cette liberté de parole
qui existe sous de multiples
formats aujourd’hui.
On a parlé du pitch,
mais il y a aussi les podcasts,
les vidéos, les réseaux sociaux
et les TED.
Chacun d’entre nous peut créer
sa chaîne YouTube
quasiment en trois clics aujourd’hui.
Et ça, c'est merveilleux.
Mais pour quoi faire ?
Juste pour exister, pour défendre
ses idées, pour partager.
Dans quelle intention ?
Parce qu’on peut tout dire, tout,
mais tout va dépendre de l’intention
que l’on va mettre derrière les mots.
Le hic, c’est que, bien évidemment,
il y a beaucoup de dérives
à cette parole libre.
On va forcément rencontrer
sur notre route des menteurs,
des manipulateurs,
des gens malintentionnés.
Est-ce qu’on peut les reconnaître ?
Oui, moi, je pense que oui.
Si on est bien attentif,
on va pouvoir ressentir
cette mauvaise intention,
cette fausseté de message,
derrière des expressions du visage, un
ton de parole, une gestuelle corporelle,
qui va nous montrer comme
un décalage avec le contenu.
Et ce décalage va déclencher
une forme de vigilance en nous.
Mais s’il vous plaît, ne gâchons pas
cette liberté de parole.
En réalité, il y a des bénéfices
bien plus grands
à s’exprimer avec authenticité
et alignement.
Quand la tête, le cœur et le corps
communiquent le même message
avec la même conviction,
si l’intention est bienveillante,
la parole libre peut faire des miracles.
Quand on est aligné,
on est ancré et on prend sa place.
Et quand on prend sa place,
on est juste et on rayonne plus.
Et quand on rayonne, on inspire,
on donne envie aux autres de faire pareil.
Et ensuite, c’est un cercle vertueux,
parce que quand on touche
les gens avec notre parler-vrai,
les rencontres et les connexions
se multiplient.
Et de ces rencontres peuvent se passer
des nouveaux projets, des nouvelles idées
et on ne sait pas jusqu’où
ça peut aller derrière.
Le champ des possibles est infini.
Quel est le grand bénéfice à tout ça ?
Quand on est authentique,
quand on est vrai,
la puissance est là.
Alors souvenez-vous,
une prise de parole réussie est
une prise de parole préparée et incarnée.
Avec trois mots magiques : sourire,
enthousiasme et conviction.
Et moi,
j’ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à vous
partager mon histoire librement ce soir.
Ça m'a mise en joie.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)